that these experiences the tears flowed
as pacific islands community leaders and
those affected by the dawn raids
gathered in auckland's town hall they
came to hear new zealand's prime
minister jacinda raderne
say the words they've been calling for
for decades
today i stand on behalf of the new
zealand government
to offer a formal and unreserved apology
to pacific communities for the
discriminatory implementation
of the immigration laws of the 1970s
that led to the events of the dawn raids
the immigration crackdown in the 1970s
targeted pacific islanders
who had been brought here because of
labour shortages the often violent dawn
raids which the government has now
apologized for
saw police searching homes businesses
and even churches
looking for overstays to deport the
response from the police
was overwhelming it was very reactionary
and it was very violent the sense of
injustice is still felt today
mainly because it was only pacific
islanders who were targeted
not the majority of overstayers who were
at the time
from the united states or europe a
formal government apology for past
injustices is rare in new zealand and
has to meet strict criteria
including the victims being definable as
a distinct group that continues to
suffer harm
connected to those historic events today
many of those affected
feel a sense of shame about what
happened and are reluctant to talk about
it
even to their families you would have
just felt like
you were trampled on in some way
emotionally spiritually
in many many ways and i think that has
been intergenerational
leaders in new zealand's polynesian
communities welcome the apology
and they hope it'll help people of the
pacific islands move on
be able to stand proud because
of who we are and achieve the very very
basic and simple goals for why we even
came to this country
that's all we want they also hope saying
sorry will help build trust between the
island communities and the government
and ensure future generations feel
secure in new zealand
even if the apology has taken nearly 50
years
wayne hey al jazeera auckland